(upbeat music)
^- Hello, I'm here with Bobby.
^- Hi.
- [Ella] Bobby was one of the first
BuzzFeed Video employees back in the day.
When did you start?
- [Bobby] Like 2013.
- [Ella] Back in an office that we called Stony Bros.
- And this is the backdrop of early days
where it's like, what is a BuzzFeed video?
- Yeah, so it didn't help our image at all.
Like, a few times, we had celebrities come by,
and I was like, yep, this is our trash hole.
- [Bobby] Yeah.
- We didn't have interns
or really anyone to help out with anything,
so I remember that dishes would pile up in the sink.
- [Bobby] Mm-hmm.
There was a huge gnat--
- There was a gnat problem.
- I think we ended up moving because of the gnats,
'cause we just didn't want to deal with it anymore.
- We were just like, here, just take it, gnats.
- There were so many, and I remember in the videos,
you could sometimes see them flying through the frame.
- Guys, I found out why we have fruit flies.
(singing dramatically)
- Then after that, we moved to a house.
- My office was in a bedroom,
and other people working at Buzzfeed
would just lay on the bed.
- I had my one bed that I would work from,
and I would be all cozy, and I would be editing from it.
- Yeah.
- What were the things that you did,
like, your favorite things
that you did while you were at Buzzfeed?
- The Creep videos.
^- Yeah, they were a hugely popular series
^back in the day, starring Andrew Ilnyckyj.
How did that come about?
That was such a funny, very unique video series.
- [Bobby] So, Andrew was an intern at the time.
- [Ella] Yeah.
- [Bobby] And I just liked his voice.
If he says anything, it's hilarious.
And we did this video, I think it's called
Tea Versus Coffee?
- Yes!
- Where it's just
his voiceover, and it was so funny,
and we were trying to figure out something,
and I don't know how it came up,
but the Creep thing came up.
There was a mystery about him.
^- Yeah, his voice was really deep.
- I really like your style.
I think I'll follow you.
- The first one you shot was in Stony Bros.
^- It was just like the creepy person in the office,
^and so, there was no frame,
and it was just him being a weirdo,
and that's maybe my favorite one
because there is no point to it.
- There's no point, and it's just like,
back in the day, we didn't really have any lights.
The vibe of this video is very shadowy,
and it's like, what is happening?
- What was the one that catapulted into super stardom?
- [Ella] 'Cause that one didn't really take off.
^- [Bobby] No, I think it was Creepy Things Girls Do?
^- [Ella] Yeah, that had like five million views.
- [Bobby] Yeah.
It was like our biggest hit of all time, at the time.
- [Andrew] I'm not wearing any underwear.
- I knew we hit the big time when some
German magazine called, Buzzfeed, and was like,
"We want to interview Andrew," or something.
And I was like, what?
- Yeah, and it was just this thing where
he didn't even have a name, really.
- [Bobby] No.
He was just called "Buzzfeed Creep."
- And, to be fair,
I don't think Andrew completely loved being the creep.
Like, he was resistant.
- [Ella] He did it.
- [Bobby] And the other thing that I enjoyed
about the Creep series was my friend Matt,
who I knew since film school, basically was
the punching bag in every Creep.
So, I just enjoyed taunting Matt.
- [Matt] I just have no idea why they
have to make three Hobbit movies.
(glass smashing)
- He was a great character in all of it.
Our favorite role, that we always
talk about, when he played Gerald.
- [Bobby] That was a roommate video.
- [Ella] Yeah.
- [Bobby] That was my last video at Buzzfeed,
was the roommate video, and I,
of course, had to torture Matt.
I don't know where the hell it came from.
But it was this weird character who had a dead squirrel,
that he needed to refrigerate.
- We reference Gerald all the time.
So, Bobby, what have you been up to all these years?
- [Bobby] I made a feature film.
- [Ella] Oh, my god!
- [Bobby] It's called, The Cleanse.
- [Ella] When is it out?
- It comes out May 4th.
- Oh my gosh, you guys.
If you guys want to check out the trailer,
the link is in the description below.
Give it a watch.
Give it a thumbs up.
Thank you Bobby, for coming, for reminiscing.
Hopefully you guys will check out his movie,
and hopefully we'll see you back here.
- Well, thank you.
- Goodbye, little guy.
- Bye.
(retro electronic music)